really really important to review what
bill scher explained to us yesterday
about the Real Clear Politics average of
recent polls uh we reported to you that
Hillary Clinton's average lead in the
Real Clear Politics average was about
seven six and a half seven percent a
couple of weeks ago was about five
percent last week and was about two
percent yesterday and as bill scher told
us yesterday part of the day-to-day
change in the Real Clear Politics
average is because of movement in the
polls but part of the day-to-day change
in that average is because the polls
that are included as the recent ones
rotate over time so let's take a look
today at where the poll stand just hours
I'll still say days but we're getting
down to where we could also almost say
hours before the election note that the
ABC Washington Post tracking poll which
has been the one heavily publicized to
have Trump ahead over the last 24 hours
now is back to having Hillary Clinton
plus to note that Rasmussen which
recently had Trump up uh there are
instances here where Clinton is up in
the Rasmussen poll instances where Trump
is up most recently Trump plus three
according to rasmussen reports and then
also look at the IBD ti PP tracking poll
which was another one that yesterday had
Donald Trump up now that has a tie The
Closer that this race remains the less
likely it is number one that libertarian
Gary Johnson gets five percent he was
averaging around four point something
percent in the graph I just showed you
the Libertarian Party needs five percent
to receive public funding in the next
election cycle I do not believe that
Gary Johnson is going to get five
percent nationally however even though
the polling has gone slightly back in
Hillary Clinton's favor in the last 24
hours nationally her odds of winning
according to the fivethirtyeight.com
forecast have dropped drastically let's
put that graphic up on the screen and
you will see here that from a high
around roughly mid-october nearly a
ninety percent chance of winning
presidential election on tuesday now
nate silver is assessing this race as
basically two to one in favor of Hillary
Clinton about a sixty-seven percent
chance of winning for Hillary Clinton
and about a thirty three percent chance
of winning for Donald Trump now does
this reflect the actual numbers or does
this reflect the change in momentum and
it is over accounting for that change in
momentum well I don't know but that talk
about angry Trump supporters emailing me
saying how can I not realize that Donald
Trump is going to have a blowout win
here we don't know what's going to
happen Pat but I'm remembering in 2012
remember when Mitt Romney he really
thought he was going to win we found out
from that documentary MIT which is
extraordinary documentary he was truly
shocked by the fact that he lost handily
to Barack Obama in November of 2012 this
time the polls are generally saying it's
bad for Trump and yesterday Kellyanne
Conway we learned actually said that
Trump doesn't even care whether he wins
or loses and some of his supporters are
the ones who seem convinced that he's
way way up it's sort of the opposite of
2012 if you remember Mitt Romney claims
he didn't even write a concession speech
before he went out there tour I mean
thirty-three percent that's a real
chance and I think it's going to be
called late into the hours of the night
and we're gonna have to look at the
swing states i mean north carolina could
could tip it north New Hampshire on this
there's gonna be a few to look at will
do I mean maybe you'll submit to me your
electoral map prediction next tuesday i
will be submitting one to the audience
and remember that last year i was one
hundred percent correct in my electoral
map prediction every single state I was
right about and so were millions of
other people i'm sure i mean it wasn't
that surprising what the results were
lastly how are things looking electoral
e here's the map as of just minutes ago
on electoral dash vote dot-com 317 for
Hillary Clinton 221 for Donald Trump and
of course 270 is the number needed we
will follow it we will know the results
in just a few more days with the
election next week we have had bet d
si.com as a sponsor this week and I've
been talking about it
earlier in the week and and as my case
has been pretty clear to people who are
just so confident and they can set it
consider themselves betting folks if
you're so confident in knowing what's
going to happen on Tuesday next tuesday
november eighth uh then you can go on
Betty si.com it's been around over 20
years you can bet on Hillary versus
trump nationally they've got
state-by-state odds and the odds mirror
what the real world polls and predictors
are telling us go to bed d si.com enter
promo code Pakman 25 that's PA ke ma and
25 and you'll get a free $25 to back
your favorite candidate or whatever
election bet you want to make that
you're confident in my prediction is
that on November 9th we will hear from
some of our audience that has gone on
Betty si.com and used pakman 25 as the
coupon code as the promo code that has
won some money and no doubt I mean this
is why they call them odds we're going
to hear from some people people that
have been trolling me for months saying
David you're so stupid you have no idea
what's going on in this election here
what's going here's what's going to
happen who have decided to go on Betty
si.com and bet that are going to be very
very disappointed come very early on
november nine or as as increasingly i'm
thinking we will know late on november
eighth east coast time so go to bed d
si.com use promo code pakman 25 and put
your money where your mouth is with the
trolling election prediction emails that
people keep sending me